M it's God
it's it's
God it's
God what's he's on stream you guys want
to cross streams yeah I don't yeah sure
sure for sure so come on I'm I'm yeah
okay so so what what is this what is
this so so what this is is we're here in
t Square we're challenging people on
these topics right so proving Jesus is a
Muslim we're offering $2,200 to whoever
can he is musl that's I just donated
money
it should be that easy right he's he's a
smart guy he's a scholar he knows I'm
not a
scholar who is this guy so you're the b
with I'm not a scholar though I'm I'm a
pro boxer who want the Box okay there
you go go I box everybody right now I'm
not debating I box between right now do
who I'll box you for 2200 right now you
probably beat me do you who let's do no
let's box for
22 let's box for 2200 how about that
play 22 how about
that how about
we got heav we
got
take coming up to me like you're about
to do
something yeah yeah you in the we
good I like the
Jack so who's the who's theway sh want
to box
bro come on hey B big
day
[__] call me AAR and I'm a pro bo bo Deb
at somebody I'm not a scholar
though who's David W's guy David Wood's
friend uh de
apet job did we we put him we put on we
put him on I'm not a schar though n bro
I'm box
box we can you know what I'm saying come
on we can box got GL so y y'all set up
the debate with them yeah we we just put
him on the debate that's it did he talk
it all he
knows know your stuff I'm not a scholar
bro none of us are
scholar baby hold baby oh yeah all we do
is we don't we don't do get you right
get you right get you give me one that's
it give me 30 seconds give me 30
second 7 and nice nice nice nice nice
give so who is anybody Pro yet anybody
Pro yet anybody Pro yet yeah he Pro too
you Pro too bro everybody we can do a
five on five right now where can we find
y'
fights big big Rhino big Rhino show big
Rhino big Rhino show everywhere all
platforms y one more thing yo yo yo
everybody don't listen to these fools
out here man don't listen to these fools
out here
brus is Jesus Is God Jesus Is God Jesus
Is God y don't get atten I'm Christian
which side am I want to talk to
us you
side the son right no no he's always
existed If he if he has the same nature
the son of God because he beat I'm
trying no I'm trying to answer you look
so if he's the son of God what we mean
is is that he is he comes from the
father's Essence eternally okay so
there's an eternal uh pression from the
father that that happens with the son
it's almost like this imagine this the
sun always has light in the sky right
the sun always has light right if the
sun always has light imagine that the
sun is eternal in the sky if the
Sun come on no she was listening no so
so like watch this yeah but it doesn't
make sense you you got let me finish
believe he's God you got to let meish
believe he's a son you cannot you're not
allow you're not allow me to finish for
us he's a messenger of God and we love
him we love
Jesus I hear what you're saying but this
is what I'm saying look if you're saying
saying but but you're not even out
hearing me out I am hearing you I've
been hearing you out okay so so okay so
how did I explain his eternal nature how
did I explain that did you hear that it
it didn't make sense to me what did I
say what do you mean like it's eternally
Essence like can
God or either he's a son what do you
mean so this so I'll tell you what I
mean okay so it's like this when we say
that he's the son of God Son of the
father it means that he shares the same
Divine Essence as God okay so everything
that makes believe Jesus created
everything everything everything all the
all the universe yes the Quran says the
Quran says the same thing no wait wait
show me where it says so like for
example show me where it says Jesus
created well I got you for example no I
want to see can I give you can I give
you so Allah says in the Quran that
everything is created by his word right
the heavens and the Earth came into
existence through his word right now the
Quran also says in chapter 4 verse uh
171 it says that Jesus is Allah's word
so if Jesus is Allah's word yeah oh it
doesn't say that Jesus is a messenger of
God
spread he spreaded God's word yes he
spreaded God's word but he's not God
himself okay so okay I got you so you're
saying he spread the message of God but
he's not God himself the messenger of
God just like Prophet Muhammad prophet
other prophets M like all the other ones
he's a prophet he's not God so I got you
so let me ask you this a human cannot be
God if God created human he cannot be
God himself I got you can a human can a
human be God's word he spreaded God's
word no not spreading it cuz I know what
you're saying he spread the word there's
a difference I got you sent him in yeah
I'm not saying that I'm saying can a
human be God's actual word what do you
mean like be God's of God the word of
God itself when it says that God created
everything through his word he says the
heavens and the Earth was created
through his word can a human be the word
of God be the word I don't I don't go
they can only spread the word of God
right they can't be God's word itself
because that would mean that they are
the same as Allah they come from no no
no God sent all the prophets to spread
what he had what he wanted the world to
know through through prophets messenger
of God understand this is what they are
but see that's my difference the
difference Jesus is that the Quran says
that Jesus is the word of God not that
he spread it but he is the word itself
show I got you thank I've glad you ask
right and the spirit of Allah that's
right so look wait wait I want to see
where where in the Bible the one that
was original not the one that's been
like you know how how you know the
difference I want to see where Jesus
said Jesus himself said that he's not
God like he's not God he never said he's
not God so you I can show you that as
well okay he not not said that he's God
okay after this I want you show me human
be God I don't understand that like well
do you believe that God could do
anything yes of course do you believe
that if God wanted to that he could take
on human form and walk amongst us but he
didn't I know I know he wanted to he God
can do everything okay so look here's
the difference sister listen let's be
patient with each other the difference
between me and you is that look the
difference is oh no it's okay it's okay
it's okay don't it's okay so the
difference is we both believe that God
could do it if he wanted to you just
don't believe he did we as Christians
believe he did okay so you're saying how
can God be a man he can do that if he
wants how can God be God then the Son of
God like that doesn't make any sense
like either you're one like you're God
and then you send you send prophets to
like spread the message and everything
but it's not like God and then just like
oh he's the son of DW so are you are you
are you saying that that God is limited
no okay so then God could be the father
son and all the spirit right but that
didn't happen if if anything then God
can do anything you can just if if
that's the situation you're putting in
then anything can Poss can be possible I
can say oh this happened God it's
possible that the god did that well this
is what I'm saying sister all you're all
you're showing me is that you don't
really have a fundamental like uh you're
not saying that it's not possible you're
saying that you just don't believe it
happened you know what I'm saying I know
it didn't happen okay so I'm not saying
I believe I know well no no you don't
cuz you're a Muslim yeah and I know
that's the truth but I'm just saying
like God and son can't be one person
what I agree I I I agree that the father
and the son are not the same person
saying because I'm tell Jesus Is God and
he's God you said that but can I tell
you look the Trinity is not that God is
one person the Trinity is that the one
God the one Divine Essence exists as
three persons so we're saying the Son
and the father are two distinct persons
that that share the same nature I'm done
saying saying that you're done is not an
answer though you know what I'm saying
no but I got to go I'm just
saying one person he's a human he's
just God how about a how about tell me
how Jesus is a Muslim God is no Jesus is
a prophet not son and God and I don't
know but you don't know that about Jesus
you haven't read his teachings yes I
have I read the Quran what did Jesus
teach whatever God told him to teach but
where do you find that in the Quran you
can read the Quran you I've read the
Quran he doesn't have his teachings
there sister look he brought the inil
right the Quran is not the inil it's
something different so read the Quran
with translation then you'll understand
I've read it I have it on my phone yeah
but I don't think you understand it go
to a schar and he'll teach you better I
I I don't think you understand it you're
you're saying the is in thean trying to
understand you're not trying to
understand tell me something that I'm
not trying to understand okay all right
take care yeah take care of yourself I I
I encourage you to look into this cuz
you don't know what Jesus taught yep
guys so what we have here as an example
we have just a lot of emotion right a
lot of hype and a lot of that didn't
happen that didn't happen but what we
see is is that she's not rejecting that
it can happen so when Muslims are saying
how can this how can this well they
actually believe that God can do it
that's just that he didn't so what is
your real problem with the Incarnation
of Christ what is your real problem with
God coming down as man you don't have a
problem if you really have a problem you
would stick here and defend your
religion but you can't you got to run
off well if God is a racist why does
John 3:16 say that whoever puts their
faith in Jesus Christ will have
everlasting life now if God is a racist
why in Romans 11 the Gentiles are
grafted in alongside the
Jews if God is a racist why did he die
for everybody you see ay didn't say
anything racist right you see this is
what this this is Avery right here he
says so who who are you my name is
Matthew oh yeah so bottom line is God is
not a racist you know that's that's
that's a Doctrine from the pits of hell
all right so Avery here you go cook my
brother
cook my American brother let him cook
where's your sh hat at man hey I left
that
man so what did you want to say my
brother did you have a question oh try
to speak into the
and I get I get 2200 right now if what
um if I prove to you that God was um
what excuse me God Jesus is a speaker to
um Jesus was um a Muslim a Muslim now um
You don't believe that wait a minute EXC
let let's do little let's do these
little little lines yeah the small
letters so Islam Islam and Muslim are
they equivalent to you they're the same
thing yeah one and the same all right I
got you 2200 you say right
2200s huh hundreds all hundreds whatever
how you going it all you going pay the
you going pay right now you you don't
even believe Jesus is a Muslim I I
believe Jesus Christ was is um Islamic
totally no you don't I do you you can
ask me what's up so I can prove it to
you now cuz I do believe that that's how
I get the 2200 already that's how you
get the 2200 Pro he was he was he was
Islamic of course say the sh I don't I
don't speak Arabic or anything but he
definitely was Excuse Me Miss so no this
is pure business right now is money
moves he making money moov he was
Islamic totally all right
he he he he believed in in submission to
the almighty the almighty God we could
go and and and this is how I win five
you could you go back to Genesis and and
and and and the other four books and you
you'll be able to know
that you'll be able to know that Jesus
Christ n it's pressure I'm smoking on
pressure and I got cameras up in my face
and I'm about to get 2,200 for the
C so the thing about it is that
he was he was totally Muslim now um
people that are Muslim nowadays um the
difference with Christians is I I would
definitely say is the Quran I would
definitely say is the the Quran do so do
you believe that Jesus believed in the
same God that is described in the
Quran um I would totally say n o then
you lose the money man that's it that's
it he he he in order for him to be a
Muslim he has to believe in the same God
described in the Quran now now this the
thing the the flip was that the Quran is
not look at you no I'm great the thing
is that the Quran is not is not the for
me and speaking for a whole bunch of
peoples that that are alive I believe
that the Quran is not the absolute truth
not not Jesus hey com
[Applause]
up that's right you you know my body I'm
I'm I'm Red Devil right now hot but I'm
not the devil you know what I mean um
how did I lose I prove that that the
nowadays Muslim have no knowledge that
Jesus Christ was actually Muslim but he
wasn't though he was to be a Muslim you
have to submit and believe in the god
that's described in the Quran the thing
is that there's a different there's a
different um terminology on Muslims of
of 2024 no we're talk we're we're
talking about the belief system of being
a Muslim to be a Muslim you have to
believe in the same God that's described
in the Quran so so so the thing about it
is that the Quran speaks about God a a
excuse me with the two L's and H um yes
he's deep now now this is this is
Samaran this is Jesus Christ believed in
that same God he he he doesn't follows
the he doesn't follow the custom all
right let me let me tell you for example
the god that's described in the Quran
yeah he says that he's not the the
father of Jesus Jesus says that God is
his father so they're talking about two
different so the Muslims nowadays have
no idea that they that they're following
a different muslimism they're they're
following a different God they're
they're Muslims and Jesus just wasn't it
I I don't believe they're Muslim that's
why for real I believe in Islam I don't
believe
the yeah
the the you see what happened with 11
and all of that Jesus not for Real Jesus
Christ wasn't about the violence so I'm
the difference is that the Quran the
scriptures of the Quran to mind and
there's no disrespect to anybody that
follows it because everybody finds their
peace their own way the thing is that
Jesus is the peace Man without that
ain't no way to the thing is that there
was a there was a mix um um stop just
stop I'm on my 22 it's it's over how so
how look I'll tell you what
happened no I want I I want to know how
so the second that you said
that Jesus doesn't believe in the same
God that's described in the Quran yeah
that's that's right there you canel him
out from being a Muslim now wait a
minute it's over wait a
minute all I'll give you another chance
I'll give you another another challeng
money here another wait we got another
challenge 2200 do you know where the
angil is wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute trick question that's a
trick question you're
fired let [__] around I really believe
that Jesus Christ was Muslim though I
just believe I
do I believe Jesus Christ was Muslim but
the people from nowadays they're not
real Muslims because they follow the
Quran profess right now I got you so
what he's saying
guys I know what you're saying he's
saying that Jesus is the real Muslim and
the ones who call themselves Muslims
today they're not Muslims so Muhammad
wasn't a Muslim none of them were Muslim
he want to be Islamic he Muhammad to be
a Muslim
2200 and that's the difference we are
the real God is within us you know what
I mean so I know I know it seems like ay
and stuff but I'm really like that to
the point where I understand that God
God gave us the opportunity to learn of
Christ and Christ said if anybody comes
with a Doctrine different from the one
that he stated he's a lie so he's a cur
you know what I mean pring I'm keeping
it real I'm keeping it real at B on the
field on the streets say the same thing
you so so you believe the Bible of
course so what what do you think a
person has to do five I I I just Genesis
oh the book The Tor how you going to
compare Quran to the right so the
quran's all out so what according to you
and what you believe how does a person
gain eternal life I want to make it to
Heaven bro 2200 22
R this video back R this video back the
the 2200 is the 2200 gone thank you
brother I I need a water please I
thought you yeah I shout it out you know
what I mean you got mine but yeah so
according to what you believe according
what you believe what um what what what
does a person living water that's good
living water got the Living Water what
what does a person have to do to make it
into heaven um
be like Christ man what is that what is
that to be to be real to be real and if
you if we could say the word Muslim we
could say Islamic which is which is the
difference 22 if the if the title of the
video is prove that Jesus Christ um was
a Muslim right so that that's gone we
passed that no I think he was a Muslim
actually you think that but you can't
you're going to run the video back
you're going to understand that I was
actually saying that he was a Muslim
it's people that nowadays AR real
Muslims so I I got I got what you're
saying but if I'm trying to make it to
Heaven what does it mean to be like
Christ pay me my 2200
y I got to pay Caesar with the Caesars
who's paying I don't know if it's you
you didn't prove it man you didn't prove
it he's Muslim now people people hey man
I'm not sorry I'm hey you're going to
run it back I'm all right I'm all right
no I said I'm sorry I'm sorry you you
don't get it so I got to really let you
know you don't get it it don't mean what
it mean wait let me
you you can't you can't redefine What
Muslim is and then say yeah Jesus fits
that n n Jesus Jesus don't fit the Quran
Y which is what makes a Muslim no that's
wannabe that's wannabe I'm talking about
the Real Islam okay let me ask you this
when does the word Muslim coming to come
and like to to play when was it invented
do you
know are you going to pay me my 22 if I
prove to you that if you prove that
Jesus was a Muslim not this other madeup
Muslim that you're coming up with
talking about real Muslim oh so you want
to know what a Muslim is I already know
what a Muslim is so what's the Muslim
for you one who submits their will to
Muhammad fully and and and without
resistance and that's and you we we both
know that's
[__] both we all know this Jesus
Jesus Christ he not a Muslim so you're
not a Muslim I he's not a Muslim nor is
Jes I don't believe in Muhammad NE and
neither did Jesus I believe I believe in
I believe in the real believe I believe
I I believe in the real Muslim Community
in the Real Islam not no fake K on let's
go cast out and harm each other's
Brothers nah
n Jesus Christ wasn't a Muslim for
nowadays he was a he was a real Muslim
that followed the five the the the real
books of the Bible all right so so to to
be to fit this that's how you get to
John Matthew so to fit the description
here you have to prove that Jesus is an
actual Muslim in the real term of the
word musl Muslim is to be pure
but it's not though it's not no for you
for you for you a Muslim is a Muhammad
yeah
Muhammad it's a Muhammad Muhammad and
yeah those who follow Muhammad all right
all right so so Jesus don't there's no
way Jesus could follow
Muhammad now now my let me let me prove
my my stance
though I need I need another
contestant we need another contestant
we need another you tried you tried
that's good but when you say the Bible
is
true what what appears to me as true is
something that's objective right and
something that can be empirically proven
but the the I Love Jesus Christ like I'm
not even a I'm not even Christian but I
love because I love the message right do
un to others as you want done love thy
enemy all that but the the problem I
have is with like the Virgin birth right
because that that doesn't Pro prove like
it's scientifically impossible and
because it's more than almost 2,000
years ago it's hard
to prove this so how can you say with
such coni like conviction that this is
true the Bible is true when I think it's
you maybe your truth but is it
empirically true I got you so so first
to to tell you why I say the Bible is
true one is because of the resurrection
of Jesus that's why I believe and
everything else before that right but
but to answer so the resurrection is
like what proves Christianity if you
show that the resurrection didn't happen
Christianity is false and our faith is
in vain that's literally what the Bible
says right now right there how can you
prove the otherwise that it did happen
yeah so but I'm going to get to that I
just want to address the empirical part
okay so from what you were saying it's
it's almost like you're saying that that
truth or proofs can only be established
empirically which I don't agree with and
I don't think that you even live by that
I don't I don't because there's things
that happen we can yes but isn't it not
hear say if we do following some oral
tradition that we recorded or something
is it hearsay is it safe to say I
wouldn't say hearsay I but cuz you have
eyewitness testimony now it is testimony
that you get everything we know about
history is going to be from someone what
someone said right but what what people
recorded and stuff like that the thing
about Jesus is that we have so much
historical information about him early
historical information about him right
that even atheists and agnostic Scholars
have to say yes Jesus for a fact existed
and it's a certain fact of history that
he was crucified under Pontius Pilate
right they don't have the wood that he
was crucified on or like that but they
see by from the high witness testimony
that he was crucified not in the I'm not
debating if he existed or not my my
focus was on the Virgin birth yeah so
all of that all of that is pertaining to
Jesus if he was resurrected then
everything he said about about himself
and everything was said about him is
true but but another reason why I bring
this up because if we look at historical
context then we can see that in those
times people were stoned to death and
for numerous reasons such as adultery so
if we put our ourselves in the context
of a a woman who saying have a child out
of wedlock we can say that the best case
scenario is for her to say
this is a miraculous birthday and I
never had sex with anyone to save my
life is that now a possibility well yeah
you're saying it's a Poss it's possible
for somebody to lie about such a thing
but also it's possible that God who's
telling the truth and Jesus who told the
truth about himself that he truly was
born of a virgin because he claimed to
be the Messiah the M the scripture says
that the Messiah was going to be born of
a virgin and Jesus says I am that
Messiah that the coming from the Torah
okay okay I'm unaware of that but also
that's that's Isaiah 7:4 but you know
it's interesting to talk about and I do
think that Christianity is more positive
for the world other than other
ideologies and I think like I think we
now that Trump won we're in a time where
we got free speech and hopefully we can
bring these discussions to the table in
academics especially cuz I go to a lot
of meetings at Colombia NYU the moment
you say something that goes against to
what they're saying they want to shut
you down and I think it's time we stand
up for the truth absolutely so before
you go I want to ask you then what you
love Jesus's teachings his teachings you
know you believe that you know is like
Christianity of anything Christianity is
the good one right what's stopping you
from accepting Christ uh it's not
accepting Christ it's accepting like I
don't want to play for any team because
I see like I I have an Indian background
India was divided using religion to
separate people if if if one religion is
doing it another religion is doing it I
don't want to be a part of no religion I
rather just be a humanist okay but you
like Jesus I do Jesus said that he I
don't like him I love him okay Hees all
right so look so look because he's a
pacifist he but but he he peaceful
though but he peaceful like I know
you're you're trying to meet me halfway
he gave up himself for Humanity and he
tried to show the Heretics that you're
doing something wrong and I think people
Heretics are still doing stuff wrong
like in Iran in Pakistan even in India
killing people for beef for whatever
this is wrong so let so let me show you
what Jesus said here about splitting
Jesus said that he came right not to
being priest but a sword but in what
context he says that he comes to bring
truth right because truth divides so if
somebody isn't truth he says that you
know mother and mother will will will go
against her daughter for my name's sake
or a son will go against his father
because of me and if you don't give up
your own life for my sake then you will
lose it right and so what he's teaching
is is that he's the way right he's the
truth and that because of him
people and even families will be divided
because he stands in truth and it's
exclusive it is truth is exclusive now
because of that Jesus says look man it's
either you're on this team or you're on
the wrong team this is what Jesus says
what what so if Jesus is teaching this
right and we know how much he loved
people we know how much he taught love
and respect and all these kind of stuff
but he taught exclus
exclusivity right you know I get what
you're saying I think there will be a
time for me where Maybe I'll put in a
position where I have to pick something
but until then I'm still investigating I
I encourage everyone to always
investigate and don't get suck trapped
into whatever your parents teach you
just because they teach you that look
into the resurrection okay will will I
think with you the resurrection will do
do it that's right all right take care
man thanks for coming bro God bless you
man oh my God logic
nah
[Music]